what do you do to relax so you've had a
full day of acting like a crazy person
on camera when you get home what do you
do didn't I do I do a couple of things
that are that might people might find
surprising primarily I do jigsaw puzzles
aggressively complicated jigsaw puzzles
but then I also have recently become
obsessed with the game the video game
Red Dead Redemption to anybody okay it's
a huge game huge game that came out last
year and I'm not a gamer I don't know
I've seen your segments of clueless
gamer yeah I'm we're comparable oh
you're not as good at it I'm actively
not good at it such that this is a Wild
West theme game it's basically like a
game where you're in like the Sergio
Leone Spaghetti Westerns kind of right
when I tell you how much time I spend
trying to get on my horse and instead
punch my horse all I'm doing in the game
is jumping up and down and punching my
horse because I'm supposed to be getting
away from police like like I've
committed a crime they're after me and
I'm like run run run punch punch punch
I'm punching the [ __ ] out of my horse
can't get on it I get caught every time
right so now the whole thing that I've
decided to do in the game I've abandoned
all of the missions all of the bad guy
stuff I don't like the morality I spend
the whole game hunting and fishing I
mean it's kind of sweet
I guess I'm wasting profound amount of
time and game just hunting just tracking
a cougar yeah then it jumps on my head
and kills me every time again bad at the
least that's hunting a cougar the part
where you're just sitting there with a
fishing rod with your controller that's
ridiculous Reed and the the what that
the dexterity it takes to reel in a fish
seems to me to be impossible yeah
I'm losing fish cut iams I'm standing up
I'm screaming at the TV just because I'm
some dumb fish got away from me yeah
just as I was so close I'm 46 years old
you need to stop yeah I'm alone in a
home I am a stylist and wifeless playing
a game in my underwear fired up at the
TV